نحن هنا على حدود قطاع غزه حيث يسود هدوء
حذر لكنه يبدو هشا قابلا للانكسار في اي
لحظه بعد التصعيد الخطير وهو الاخطر عمليا
منذ اربعه اشهر منذ الحمله العسكريه
الاسرائيليه الاخيره على قطاع غزه مرد هذا
التصعيد تقول اسرائيل انه التصعيد الحاصل
دراماتيكيا في الضفه الغربيه
المحتله همم وهنا اسرائيل باتت عالقه في
معادله تحاول الافلات منها وهي ان اي جبهه
تنفجر يمكن لها ان تفجر الجبهات الاخرى ان
كان في القدس او الطفل الغربيه المحتله او
هنا في قطاع غزه وعلى الارض تبقي اسرائيل
حالته بالقسوه من خلال نشر المزيد من
بطاريات القبه الحديديه على حدود قطاع غزه
وفي المنطقه الجنوبيه وسط خشيه لدى
المؤسسه الامنيه في اسرائيل من ان الحكومه
المغتربه ووجود المتطرف بين كبير فيها
وزيرا للامن الداخليه يفجر حربا جديدا على
قطاع غزه في حال ذهب لاقتحام المسجد
الاقصى او حاولت تغيير الواقع هناك
بالاضافه الى التصعيد الحاصل اساسا في
الضفه الغربيه المحتله